how did the Amazon how did the trip
there change you what do you remember of
it such a magical place
I stripped a lot of my past
symbols and talismans
well I was while I was there what I what
I
I remember getting there and and and
just having so much adrenaline on the
anticipation
anticipation of getting to the Amazon
in the first 10 days
I wasn't really enjoying the trip I was
just charging to get to the destination
to get to the banks of the river that I
had a dream about
and then it just
humbled me I got so fatigued
on night whatever 12.
and was so sick and tired of the
internal dialogue I was having with
myself
I was not enjoying my company
that
you know I I I I purged and I remember
and then and and and stripped off
identity markers that I had sort of been
hanging on to for like everything from
you know what it means to be an American
my Dad's ring M from McConaughey a
meltdown of my mom and dad's class rings
from University of Kentucky were gold
from her teeth and and and and and that
his
Clash ring melted down you know put
taking that off was really hard to go
I'm casting Am I Casting out my father
I wasn't casting him out I was just
removing to say I don't have to rely on
that being all of my identity so to pull
that off to to to strip down and just to
where I was just a a mammal
that next morning I
I was light I got present I remember
writing something down it's like all
that I want is what I can see and what I
can see is in front of me that sense of
not I wasn't leaning around looking
around every corner to get there and as
soon as that hit me talk about mystical
successes and realities and Truth as
soon as that hit me and for the first
time in 12 days I didn't care about
getting there what was around the corner
guess what was around the next game
corner
the Amazon
I mean not around a few Corners the next
corner there it was
that was just like a touche you know
those times when
the prime mover the universe God what
we want to name or believe in says ding
there you go
and
[Applause]
that
form of Detachment from
holding on
for dear life to things in past
so hard that you're not letting the
beauty that's right in front of you to
feel correctly and follow our intuitions
to have those not cast them out I didn't
burn them I didn't get rid of those
things I just took them off and had to
recognize you're still here you are you
you're much more that is a Talisman
that's a symbol that means something to
you and that's good don't cast out the
meaning but it's not like
when the Ring's off and the hat's off
and the crucifix is off your neck that
you're like you're gonna die and I know
those are reminders
hang on to what they mean for you
as we go forward but as we go forward
quit worrying about so much about
you again I was looking at the
proverbial dream the cloud so much that
I was tripping over myself to get there
and like clockwork Just Amazing Grace
boom as soon as it hit me and I was like
ah that's it
all I want is what I can see and all I
can see is in front of me
literally looking down at the ground
at What was a sea of ten thousand Wild
neon blue Amazonian butterflies on the
ground
as soon as they fluttered up my head
came up with them
I took a few more steps and
there's the Amazon that's what you came
over here for oh howdy those kind of
that that truth like that
well the Amazon is interesting too
because it really has no past or future
losing the moment because how fast it
churns it just eats up life
it like if a thing dies it just gets
swallowed up
because uh maybe because of the humidity
because of all that because there's so
many living creatures that kind of eat
each other live on each other
so it really exists in the moment
and all this kind of diversity of Life
there it's such an interesting place
talk about food chain yeah you're just
part of it there yeah
we we humans somehow Escape that food
chain but we're still the roots are
still there
oh yeah I think we're a bit arrogant to
think we've escaped
you think I'm being romantic and that in
that in that notion well sometimes when
you're in a big city
when you're in Austin Texas and La you
can think like oh there's we're in a car
we're in the house we're safe but
yeah somehow somehow's Nature's still a
part of us Our Roots are still part of
us
I think it is more than we realize more
than we give it credit for I actually
haven't I
believe that we
are
but it's a really arrogant notion to
think that
we are separate meaning you know people
talk about
pollution and on a larger scale the the
climate what have you
I think Earth's gonna be just fine yeah
we maybe not be here for it but
I think we have a bit of arrogance
sometimes to think that we
can Trump Mother Nature I think we have
more more of the natural law in us
um
and I sure hope so if I'm wrong